okay so I didn't know this but Derek
Brunson was recently released yeah out
of nowhere yeah out of nowhere and his
record's not too bad like he just lost
2-0 against Jerry cannonier and drika
suplesias which you know he was on a
straight up run before that it seems
like the UFC is doing a thing kind of
what they did with Nate Diaz like go
wreck the ball Brothers
oh okay we're gonna release you and your
mission is to beat Jake Paul okay so
that's what he's wanting to do to fight
Jake ball I think UFC's like go do your
thing go beat Jake Paul we're gonna
release you beat Jake Paul and then you
come back because they're not gonna
entertain like yeah he's still UFC
fighter everyone let him fight Jake Paul
because that opens up the flood gates
nope we release you go beat him quit the
hype there and then come back that's
what I think happens otherwise it makes
no sense he lost two of the very best I
I think they're just released in the
hounds and they want to take out the
Paul Brothers
by any means necessary not the easiest
fight for dick Bronson not exactly known
for uh his boxing